And the Midianites sold Joseph into Egypt unto Potiphar,
an officer of Pharaohs and captain of the guard.
And Joseph was brought down to Egypt and Potiphar,
an officer of Pharaoh,
captain of the guard,
and Egyptian bought him of the hands of the Ishmaelites,
which had brought him down.
Thither so now he's a slave.
So now you'd think,
well,
that would be,
this is a man who has a lot of reason to be irritated at the structure of
reality,
right?
He's gone from being the favorite to being betrayed by all of his brothers.
That's pretty rough.
And then he's being transformed into a slave and now he's being,
he's being sold to work as a slave.
So you'd think that that would corrupt his character because you know,
one of the things,
I think this is the case anyways,
I think people are always looking for an excuse to have their character
corrupted.
Because if your character is corrupted,
then you get to lie and you get to cheat and you get to steal and you get to be
trade and you get to act resentfully and he get to do nothing.
And that's all easy.
It's easier to lie than to tell the truth.
It's easier to do nothing than to do something.
So there's always part of you thinking,
well,
I need a justification for being useless and horrible because that,
that'd be a lot less work.
And so then if something terrible comes along,
you think,
Aha,
that's just exactly the excuse that I was waiting for.
And then out all of outcomes,
you know,
a soldier Dimson when he was in the concentration camps in Russia,
watching how people behaved,
you know,
he said that there were people that were put into camps who immediately became
trustees,
are guards,
and they were even more vicious than the people who had been hired as guards.
And his idea was that they had collected all that,
he called it fallenness,
if I remember correctly,
around them in normal life.
But they didn't have the opportunity to express it.
But as soon as you gave them the opportunity,
it was like there,
it was right away.
And so,
yeah.
So one of the messages that seems to echo through these old testament stories is
that just because something terrible happens to you doesn't mean that you get to
be,
that you get to wander off the path and make things worse.
And maybe it doesn't matter how terrible it is that what happens to you.
That's a tough call,
you know,
because you see people now and then in life who they've really got it rough man,
like 50 bad things are happening to them at the same time and you think,
oh,
it's no wonder if you are bitter and resentful and hostile and be like,
yeah,
no wonder.
But then you meet people and social needs and again talked about this in the
Gulag archipelago.
He said he met lots of people in the not lot.
He met enough people to impress him in the concentration camp system who didn't
allow their misfortunes to corrupt them.
And that's something man,
because maybe the only real misfortune is to become corrupted.
That's a really useful thing to think.
You know,
maybe the rest of it,
maybe the rest of it is trivial in comparison.
I know that's a rough thing because you can be in very harsh circumstances,
but I do think there's something to that.